es sind schwere vorwürfe gegen die
polizei in münchen die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen hat heute im
rahmen von ermittlungen gegen 21
polizisten insgesamt 37 objekte in
bayern durchsucht bei den ermittlungen
die bereits seit juli 2018 laufen geht
es unter anderem um vermutete verstöße
gegen das betäubungsmittelgesetz und das
ausgerechnet in dem bundesland mit den
härtesten drogengesetze deutschlandweit
bei den ermittlungen geht es um koks
dealer und einen promi club in münchen
und zwar das hart und genau dort steht
jetzt auch mein kollege karl kein kann
sagt uns was genau hat er in der klub
mit diesem fall zu tun
ja die münchner polizisten sollen hier
in diesem promi club am lenbachplatz
direkt im herzen von münchen ein und aus
gegangen sein
sie sollen mit einem großdealer mit
einem ehemaligen großdealer befreundet
gewesen sein der sich hier versorgt hat
mit kokain unter anderem dieser
drogendealer hat dann bei der polizei
aus gepackt als er erwischt wurde bei
einer verkehrskontrolle hat gesagt dass
er hier mehrere dass er zwei polizisten
kennt und so kamen dann die ermittlungen
laufen und der druck dieser soll nach
unserer information immer ein und aus
gegangen sein
hier in diesem hart über die gästeliste
immer rein gekommen sein
und hier wohl auch seine drogen vertickt
haben auf bild-nachfrage teilen
allerdings die betreiber des harz mit
davon haben sie nie etwas mitbekommen
dass die polizisten solche kriminellen
machenschaften verwickelt worden sind
nichtsdestotrotz 2009/10 fanden hier
zwei große razzien statt einmal im april
und einmal im august
bei dir ist jetzt jemand der die
drogenszene vor allem in münchen sehr
gut kennt genau jetzt neben mir steht
rapper und der ehemalige drogendealer
felix felix kannst du etwas sagen wie
ist hier diese partyszene münchen
die werden hier drogen konsumiert als es
ist denn die man nirgendwo in
deutschland so streng mit den drogen wie
in bayern also explizit hier in münchen
polizei ist sehr hart deswegen sind die
drogen preise hoch und dementsprechend
müssen wir ein großes geheimnis drum
machen
und ja das läuft eigentlich alles sehr
versteckt habe
und dementsprechend auch meistens dann
in locations wo die leute sich zumindest
gefühlt sicher bewegen können
kennst du irgendwelche absprachen die es
gibt zwischen club betreibern und der
polizei oder auch zwischen schülern und
der polizei gibt es so was hier in
münchen
das gibt es auf alle fälle also das ist
eigentlich auch
eine gar nicht anders möglich weil die
meisten
drogen werden eigentlich dann konsumiert
oder sag ich mal szene drogen wie kokain
jetzt in dem fall werden cool konsumiert
in den clubs und da ist es eigentlich
immer so dass siemens gibt es einen
stamm dealer gibt rouladen von dem
eigentlich intern jeder weiß okay da ist
es und dann herrschen da eben auch
andere absprachen wie in dem fall jetzt
also
wie weit dieses netz geht aber ich kann
nur sagen ich habe das war ein offenes
geheimnis dass die polizisten davon
wissen ja und letzte frage kannst du
etwas zu sagen wie laufen generell
partys im hart ab
also ich denke das ist vergleichbar mit
allen anderen locations das ist im
endeffekt so dass
es für jede szene oder für ganz
exklusive gäste immer auch see paris
oder privat bereiche gibt mir einen
kleinen anderen raum kripo sage ich mal
dann leute ungestört feiern können und
eben auch drogen konsumieren können das
ist das ist da wie in jedem anderen
szeneladen sage ich mal auf das waren
die schilderung eines sextäters und dem
jetzigen relikt aus münchen aber muss
noch mal eins ganz klar sagen die
polizei münchen hat dazu ein klares
statement abgegeben solche polizisten
haben nichts in der polizei zu suchen
das hat auch innenminister joachim
herrmann exklusiv gegenüber bild gesagt
solche menschen gehören nicht zur
polizei die ermittlungen stehen jetzt am
anfang und es bleibt abzuwarten ob sich
das vielleicht sogar noch ausweitet mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren